you
so there's a word in English called an
eggers and refers to this little
protective tip at the ends of shoelaces
and if this tip is intact then the
shoelace will stay intact and will
function properly but if it's allowed to
wear down they ended eventually phrase
this is my PhD student sneaker shoe lace
you can tell a very poor very poor
tailor telomere and over the years then
this picture has gained more of a
molecular definition which we will talk
about more deal America DNA what that
looks like how it works is telomeric DNA
how what happens in terms of proteins
that assemble there and how this is a
highly regulated and dynamic structure
you